ces murs chargés d'histoire résonnent
des rires des enfants encore plus
violent de quoi faire trembler toutes
les vitres de la maison c'est un
mercredi presque ordinaire pour le
château du plessis avec un atelier
entièrement consacré au théâtre vous
sentez bien ça car le théâtre c'était la
vocation première de cet espace dédié à
la création et à la diffusion
aujourd'hui son metteur en scène n'en
est plus le seul maître car le plessis
connaît de profonds bouleversements sa
gestion n'est plus collégiale associant
artistes et public mais ce n'est pas le
seul changement on n'est plus dans la
recherche de public
qui vont venir à 20h et repartir une
heure et demie après et on se dépêche
vide de fermer des portes et de lumière
pour rentrer à la maison nous mais de
d'accueillir ici des usagers qui font
usage du lieu ça veut dire qu'ils se
l'approprient donc pour nous le plus
important c'est que les gens viennent
ici
pour passer un moment de vie des
rencontres des moments partagés autour
de la culture de ce patrimoine
exceptionnel et aussi de ce beau parc de
deux hectares avec non plus une mais
deux saisons artistiques une saison
intérieure
plus divers qui court du 1er novembre au
30 avril et on a une saison extérieure
qui court du 1er mai au 31 octobre et
sur la période extérieur on propose un
festival par mois
[Musique]
je m'appelle léa carloséma je suis
danseuse de flamenco et de contemporain
et donc en résidence permanente au
château du plessis depuis mars dernier
aucun si on soigne les artistes tous les
artistes qu'ils soient peintres
musiciens ou comme ici danseurs et
certains d'entre eux se voient même
offrir un lieu de résidence permanente
pour travailler leur création c'est bien
d'avoir un endroit où on peut répéter
voilà on peut être dans notre bulle mais
parfois on a besoin aussi d'autres
choses et justement à voir donc tous ces
artistes qui
et viennent avec des univers différents
déjà ça permet de se croiser de se
rencontrer d'échanger ça peut donner
lieu aussi à des à des partenariats et
puis ça donne une certaine aussi énergie
il ya une émulsion quand même voilà de
de savoir en bas qu'il ya luiz qui
répète la ja mathilde qui fait l'atelier
théâtre ça donne des idées ça nourrit
aussi quoi en fait
je m'appelle un but et ses danseuses
professionnelles
je m'appelle louise je suis chorégraphe
de la compagnie mash up et à camille
nous préparons un spectacle qui
s'appelle itou au château du plessis
culturelle bien sûr le projet du plessis
se veut aussi humaniste ce chorégraphe a
voulu donner sa chance à cette jeune
danseuse atteintes de trisomie 21
un beau projet c'est parce que on prend
autant de plaisir l'un que l'autre
a dansé on a de l'espace donc on peut
vraiment danser on peut vraiment créé on
peut vraiment travailler avec cam et
d'aller jusqu'au bout de ses mouvements
et on ne peut avoir une régularité
travail ce qui est très importante pour
camille qui a besoin de régularité dans
l'apprentissage dans la mémorisation
elle est payée comme moi et comme
n'importe quel artiste parce que c'est
une artiste avant tout
leur spectacle sera présenté au cours du
printemps prochain et en attendant les
nombreux festivals d'été rendez vous
pour les festivités d'intérieur un
samedi sur deux à partir du 15 janvier